we have research to show that 60 days of
meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoestrings on
the end of your dna get longer that
means your biological age is changing
so we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
i mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's
having a transcendental moment and we
now know that we can predict it and we
now know that we can induce it so then
there's the evidence there
then you take
our community and you see people with
stage four cancer with parkinson's
disease with myasthenia gravis with with
lupus with ms with brain injuries
with rare genetic disorders with vertigo
tinnitus
kidney failure all kinds of health
conditions
come to a week-long event
and then at the end of that event
they make significant strides in getting
beyond the emotions of the past now
think about this
the science says that the environment
signals the gene that's epigenetics
the end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion so as long as
you're living by the same emotion every
single day you're signaling the same
gene in the same way and if that gene is
related to a survival emotion a stress
hormone then you're down regulating the
gene and you're creating disease so when
the person trades that emotion and
really breaks free from the chains of
their past
and now they're feeling an elevated
emotion
well now they're dialing down the gene
for ms and they're up regulating the
gene for health and balance and so the
person will you say to them where's the
disease well i'm not the same person
i'm not this and and the side effect
of that is a transformation in healing
so
the funny thing about it is the person
who has the healing is not talking about
the healing
whether it's blind people seeing deaf
people hearing hearing we have crazy
evidence now
what they're talking about is how
amazing they feel
because
they're refreshed they're they're they
got a new lease on life and so now we
have evidence
in our research
and that silence is the critic to show
that what's possible for people
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the 10
habits that you need to start before
next year
enjoy
habit number two create a finisher list
with brendan burchard having my friday
finisher list
what does that mean it means like you
know i've got a list here of the things
that have to happen
by friday it's my friday finisher list
it means that monday when i go to work i
am aware of all the things i need to get
done and complete by friday and that's
what i use that unit time called a week
four is making sure i get all these
things done by friday i know that by
friday
5 p.m or whatever time i want to finish
working on friday that these list of
deliverables have happened and they are
done and they are complete for the week
and if i can stay on track with that
oh my gosh
the the year just proceeds so much more
effectively habit number three start
getting up early with robin sharma the
key thing super producers do
the best of the best
they get up early
so
here's what i wanted to share with you i
wanted to literally deconstruct the 5
a.m club concept which is just you get
up at 5 o'clock you give yourself one
hour in the greatness guide i call it
the holy hour which you're not in the
world you're not checking your
notifications you're not anywhere near
technology you're not watching the news
you're not chit chatting you're not
daydreaming you are literally running a
one hour period of practice to set up
your mindset your heart set your health
set your soul set the four interior
empires that i teach at personal mastery
academy
so that by six o'clock you feel
fundamentally different now you might be
saying robin
what
five a.m
well if you're feeling that any good
idea is going to disrupt you any new
idea will shake you up a little bit and
so if you're feeling i couldn't do that
if your mind is full of chatter on
excuses if you say you know robin i
can't win the battle of bed i can't put
mind over mattress my father couldn't
get up early mum couldn't get up early
grandpa used to sleep in i just don't
have the genetics to allow me to get up
early
yes you do we know from the research of
university college london
that it takes 66 days to wire in
neurobiologically
a new habit 66 days
and as you know from my brain tattoo
that is very well known all change is
hard at first if it wasn't hard at first
to get up early it wouldn't be valuable
change and it's messy in the middle and
it's beautiful at the end
so if you want to get up early if you
want to have a gargantuan competitive
advantage if you want to have a massive
opportunity because most people
they might have great products they
might
have a great mindset they might be great
entrepreneurs or great performers they
might be working at a great company they
might have a corporate culture that is
fantastic
but most people on the planet will never
get up at 5am and that's why it is a
gargantuan competitive advantage for you
the rest of the world is pretty much
sleeping those of us who love getting up
at five o'clock we know
it's the quietest time of the day
imagine this having one hour from five
to six
just for yourself
imagine one hour
where there's such a stillness in the
air
where you can actually breathe and think
and be
and the spartan warriors say it so well
and this if you're interested in this
concept
the book is that i've written is the 5
a.m club and one of the lines i use
comes from the spartan warrior credo and
the spartans those great warriors here's
what they used to say
the one who
sweats more in training
bleeds less
in war
and so
five to six your holy hour is simply
it's a training practice it's a training
ground like the great warriors so that
when you go out in the world you bleed a
lot less you have a lot more focus a lot
more energy you're focused on your
priorities and your values versus
society's priorities and their values
and you know what i want to say to you
some days i get up at 4 45 to start my 5
a.m protocol
and i feel exhausted and i don't want to
do it
and i say
why have i been teaching this 5am club
concept for so many years to the leaders
i work with and the people who come to
the titan summit you know and people
like richard branson have been on my
stage and steve wozniak the co-founder
of apple and shaquille o'neal was in the
room at the titan summit a number of
years ago and why do i teach this and
why do i teach the protocol
well here's the key
not only will it fundamentally change
the way your days play out but the way
you feel at six is very different from
the way you feel when you first wake up
so
give yourself 66 days please understand
that getting up early is a gargantuan
competitive advantage and it will be the
single best thing or certainly one of
the single best daily habits that you
could possibly install in your life if
you're seriously interested in legendary
leadership being a world builder and a
history maker how about number four stop
hitting the snooze button with mel
robbins this is a productivity killer
that most of us don't know about it
has to do with
waking up now when you think about being
productive if you got a big day and you
got a bunch of stuff you need to get
done most of us focus on when when do i
need to get up in order to get
everything done that's not what you need
to focus on the thing that really
impacts your productivity is how
how do you wake up and here's the deal
if you're somebody like i used to be
that hits the snooze button that kills
your productivity for at least four
hours let me explain you have to
understand this the snooze button
creates
a mental state a state in your brain
that is called
sleep inertia it's so bad it actually
has a name
here's what it is when you and i go to
bed we sleep in cycles we sleep in
cycles of like 90 to 110 minutes all
night long and right before you wake up
the sleep cycles they stop and your body
goes into a wake up mode okay your brain
is starting to slowly wake up so that it
can start the day when your alarm goes
off you're in wake up mode your brain is
now ready to do its best work however
if the alarm goes off and you hit the
snooze button
guess what you've just done
you've just made your brain go back into
a sleep cycle
your brain is now in a mode that takes
about 90 to 110 minutes to complete you
just rebooted the system so when your
alarm goes off and you get up 15 minutes
later you're now
in major trouble and the reason why
you're in trouble is because your brain
is still locked into a sleep cycle and
this is where sleep inertia comes in you
know how when you hit the snooze button
you wake up and you're like oh my gosh i
did not get enough sleep last night you
feel so groggy you kind of feel like
this mental hangover
that is sleep inertia
here's the deal
your brain the cortic region of your
brain which is responsible for decision
making attention alertness self-control
that sucker is still in a sleep cycle
and now that you're awake it's going to
take the cortal region almost four hours
to actually snap out of that sleep cycle
that's why you feel groggy it's because
the part of your brain that's
responsible for critical thinking and
being alert it's actually still asleep
if you don't already do this you've got
to train yourself to be the kind of
person that doesn't use the snooze alarm
because when you hit the snooze alarm
you're not only putting your brain in a
state of sleep inertia you are directly
impacting your productivity your
alertness and your brain processing for
the first four hours that you're awake
that's making life harder i'm all about
making life easier so tomorrow when the
alarm goes off i don't care how tired
you are i don't care how much you don't
want to get out of bed i want you to
remember this
i want you to remember that you've got
to wake up and give your brain its best
shot to do its best work
and the way you're going to do it is
five four three two one turn off that
alarm and get up seize the day
and go be productive
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number five optimize your
environment with james clear let's say
that you wanted to build a better i'll
give you i'll give you an example
breaking a good hat or building a good
habit and breaking a bad one so one of
the laws is to make it obvious and this
largely comes down to like what we're
exposed to each year each day and
minimalism and simplicity plays a big
role in this um in the book i call it
environment design that's basically the
strategy so for a long time i realized
that i brushed my teeth twice a day but
i didn't floss consistently and when i
looked at that habit one of the reasons
that i wasn't flossing consistently is
because the floss was hidden in the
drawer in the bathroom so i just
wouldn't see it you know like i wouldn't
open up the drawer and remember
so i bought a little bowl and got some
of the pre-made flossers and put them in
the bowl and place it right next to my
toothbrush so now i brush my teeth put
the toothbrush down pick the flosser up
it's right there just that one little
environment design change is pretty much
all i needed to do
to build the habit of flossing every day
um on the other side let's say you know
a lot of people feel like they spend too
much time watching tv or playing video
games or just looking at a screen
but if you walk into pretty much any
living room where do all the couches and
chairs face they all face the television
so it's like what is that room designed
to get you to do it's designed to get
you to watch tv
so there are a variety of uh
levels to this you could for example
take the remote and take it off of the
coffee table and put it inside a drawer
or you could take the television and put
it inside like a wall unit or a cabinet
so you don't see it
you could also increase the friction of
the task so you could like take the
batteries out of the remote after each
use and then you know it's an extra five
or ten seconds put it in maybe that's
just enough time if you think do i
really want to watch something or am i
just doing this mindlessly
you could
unplug the tv after each individual use
and then only plug it in if you can say
the name of the show you want to watch
so you can't like mindlessly browse on
netflix
and i mean if you really wanted to be
extreme about it you could take the tv
off the wall
put it in the closet and then only take
it out when you really wanted to watch
something but the point here and this is
kind of the the principle of environment
design in general which is
you want to put fewer steps between you
and the good behaviors and more steps
between you and the bad ones and imagine
the cumulative impact of living an
environment that exposes you to the cues
of your positive habits and reduces the
cues of your negative habits it's kind
of like you're just gently being nudged
in the right direction each day and
that's just one of the of the ways that
you can sort of design a system that
leads you into better habits in my
personal life
you know like there's a moment around 5
15 each night my wife gets home from
work and either we change into our
workout clothes and we go to the gym or
we don't change into our workout clothes
and we watch you know reruns the office
and order takeout or whatever
and really the next two hours are kind
of determined by
that decisive moment of whether we
change into our workout clothes or not
if we change it close then like
everything else is going to happen
automatically we're going to drive to
the gym i'll get it under the bar i'll
do it it's already pre-decided basically
so
one of the realizations of this and it
comes back to your kind of central
question of what you know what are the
most important habits to build or are
there ones that ripple into other areas
of life
if you can just master maybe
five or ten decisive moments throughout
the day these little kind of two-minute
chunks that determine the next block of
time
you really only have to focus your
attention and energy on that and the the
the rest of it kind of comes easily you
don't have to do that much uh if you can
master the right moments it's kind of
like judo for your personal habits you
know you apply the pressure in the right
place and everything else kind of falls
in line habit number six set deadlines
for yourself with john assaraf you've
got 8 10 12 15 hours in a day to get
done and most people are wasting time
and this is your precious asset not the
hourglass not the sand but time bruce
lee said if you value your life you will
value your time because time is what
makes up your life so let's talk about
the the concept of how to achieve more
in one day than you do in a week
here is something to consider
we all have
from the time we wake up to the time we
go to bed time a block of time
and it's comprised obviously of
our days comprised of 86
400 seconds in a day now here's what i
want you to think about if somebody gave
you eighty six thousand four hundred
dollars okay for every 24 hour period of
time
number one would you be happy would you
like yeah i just won the lottery eighty
six thousand four hundred dollars to
start off every day wouldn't you
invest that money wisely and what if
they also said to you that if you don't
spend the eighty six thousand four
hundred dollars you lose it it's gone
forever
how many of you would spend those eighty
six thousand four hundred dollars
all the way to the end and maximize it
if you would spend it just hit the like
or the love button because i would spend
it as phenomenally as i could and so
here's the thing to remember
everybody has the same amount
of seconds everybody has 86
400 seconds and so you don't have less
or more time than anybody else
and that takes me to the first point
that i want to share with you and that
was there's no such thing as time
management you cannot manage time
the only thing that you can learn
how to do better
is manage what you do
in time
now if you analyze or do any research on
highly productive people
they are two three four five times more
productive in what they do
than other people everybody and i mean
everybody is freaking busy busy with
friends busy with family busy with kids
busy with a job build busy with their
career busy doing
some of it's productive some of it is
not
write this down okay somebody type this
out
don't confuse activity
with productivity write it down for me
somebody you know write it down don't
confuse
activity with productivity okay
so
what does that mean it means that most
people are doing busy work and they're
confusing thank you sharina they're
confusing being busy and being tired at
the end of the day
with getting the most important things
done so that's why i said there is no
such thing as time management the only
thing you can manage is what you do in
the block of time
while you're awake
when you create
an action item or a list of what you
need to do
and you have a deadline to achieve it
your brain actually goes into a hyper
focused mode when you create
self-imposed deadlines and urgency
factors
so
when we teach our clients whether
they're employees or home makers or
business owners or doctors or lawyers
makes no difference
one of the things that we teach them in
addition to having a goal
and in addition to having things that
need to get done
is to create a deadline there's
something called the pareto principle
that
that that says that if you focus
on the 20
of the things
that are the most important and you set
deadlines to achieve them
you will get your brain to focus on
getting those achieved so
in addition to something called the
pareto principle there's also something
called parkinson's law when you combine
the two pareto's principle and
parkinson's law
to say i'm going to make a list of
everything that i need to get done but
i'm going to prioritize
the things that are the most important
the most urgent and i'm going to put
those onto my calendar to get them done
first not last not after i've done all
my busy work not after i've you know
been on the phone i've returned 200
emails i've texted 16 friends i've
played on facebook for two hours no no
no no that's what average people who are
busy do
versus above average people who are
productive do
you have to change your mind shift the
way you're thinking
about your time and what you do habit
number seven focus on being a learner
with tom bilyeu the single most
important part in learning to be honest
with yourself is to accept that you must
have self-esteem
and the problem is most people build
their self-esteem around something
stupid so most people build their
self-esteem around being right
being good being smart being worthy and
they see all of those as permanent
traits and so anything that challenges
them being smart which is my big one oh
god even to this day if i really want to
get into a bad place i'll just go hang
around people that are just legitimately
smarter than me and then focus on how
cool being smart is now i can be around
them when i value myself for being the
learner but the second i let myself slip
into just wanting to be cool for being
smart then being around those people is
like getting kicked in the face it sucks
man and so i had this i went through
this phase in my life that i call the
king of remedial jobs phase and i
wanted so this is post film school post
like realizing that i don't have talent
i just need to be smart man i just need
to build myself back up by being smart
and so i would apply for jobs like i
worked i sold video games retail um and
i sold insurance door-to-door i did
anything that i could where i knew that
the person interviewing me at some point
during the interview was gonna say why
are you applying for this job like
you're too smart for this and be like
i'm right where i need to be which is
crazy and sad but absolutely true and so
i did that for a couple years and in
that phase it was i just didn't want my
intelligence to be challenged so flash
forward now i'm working with these two
entrepreneurs they hire me as a
copywriter i'm in an entrepreneurial
environment for the first time and
they're
clearly smarter than me that that isn't
even up for debate and i'm
arguing with them for this idea because
i needed to win i just i couldn't take
another time where it's like they're
smarter than me they're smarter than me
so i was like all right i'm gonna win on
this idea and somewhere in the argument
i realized i was wrong and there was a
voice in my head screaming you're wrong
dude you are wrong you know you're wrong
shut up like stop pushing for this what
are you doing and i kept going and i
finally like whittled them down and they
finally just gave up and so they said
yep we'll do it your way fine whatever
and
right then and there's the one time in
my life that was truly a lightning rod
moment where my life can be divided
before and after
and that moment was realizing that i was
telling everybody that i wanted to get
rich
but the way i was acting was like i just
wanted to feel smart
and i thought hey no judgment i'm
totally cool whichever it is like we can
craft a life where that will be
wonderful so if what you really want is
to just be smart and to feel smart all
the time you have to quit you've got to
get out of this environment because they
make you feel stupid all the time and
that's not a great place to be feeling
badly about yourself all the time for
any reason even if it's self-inflicted
it's not a bad scenario or it's not a
good scenario you've got to get out of
it so i was like okay so that's option
one get out of this scenario go back to
being the king of remedial jobs
or if you actually want to get rich
start acting in accordance with it start
making decisions based on that and so i
was like okay well i'm going to have to
give up my self-esteem i'm going to have
to like stop worrying about feeling good
about myself and i was like oh
that is clearly a losing proposition
there is no way to come in and feel
horrible every day and think that i will
have the energy to see this through so i
was like god what else could i do i was
like well i guess i could build my
self-esteem around something that
is sort of impervious to being around
people that are smarter than me and what
would that be being the learner and i
thought okay well i could choose to do
that i could choose to build my
self-esteem around being
not
right but finding the right answer not
being smart but working hard to learn
and so that became just like the core of
my existence i decided in that moment
i'm going to start valuing myself for
how rapidly i can admit when i'm wrong
how much i learn how much time and
energy i put into learning and once i
switched that and i switched my identity
and my behaviors around to being the
learner then all of a sudden everything
changed and that's when i went on hockey
stick growth because all of a sudden if
we were arguing and i realized you were
right i'd be like dude he's right you're
totally right i see it oh my god thank
you so much and so i started earning a
reputation i never just backed into a
corner i never argued for something just
because it was my idea i was
legitimately on the hunt to find the
right answer and so now i'm getting the
internal feedback of hey you said that
you were going to always focus on being
the learner you're doing it you said
you'd always admit when you're wrong and
i would try to shorten that timeline
down so i wasn't like taking an hour to
finally admit it or even three minutes
that i was trying to get to it like dude
if i realized i was wrong three seconds
30 seconds max like i'm you know just
finally saying it look you're totally
right i'm with you yep i see it and then
the world was like whoa working with
this guy is awesome he's not trying to
take credit for other people's ideas he
will change on what he was saying in a
heartbeat when he you know he fights for
what he believes in but the second you
can convince him he's convinced and then
he moves on and it just became a really
awesome environment so that was hugely
transformative but it forces you to
constantly be on the lookout for where
am i wrong how about number eight stop
procrastinating with miles monroe my
greatest fear tonight is very simple and
that is i am afraid that most of you in
this room and in this auditorium tonight
and perhaps watching this program you
are going to add to the treasure and the
wealth of the cemetery
and that makes me very sad
because buried inside of you are dreams
that you still carrying
ideas that god planted in your heart
that you still haven't done yet
paintings that you've been planning to
paint and books you've been thinking
about writing and paintings you keep
procrastinating about
and what i'm so concerned about is we'll
never see your painting
we'll never sing a song we'll never read
your book and we'll never
operate in your business and we never
experience the invention that you keep
procrastinating on
i trust that you will rob the graveyard
of your treasure yes
i pray that you will disappoint the
cemetery
i pray that when the
the mall gets your carcass it'll be
empty hybrid number nine listen to your
intuition with lewis howes i was 23 24 i
read the alchemist oh
it's my favorite and like the end of the
book is like the treasure's within you
don't go look around the world trying to
find the treasure i think that was
pretty much the ending so sorry to give
it away if you haven't read it but the
treasure was within me i was like oh wow
i have all the answers i need within me
and then i started like
asking myself the questions now i'm a
professional question asker to everyone
else also now
but i've always been asking myself the
questions
and
i've found that my intuition has never
been wrong
and i go i've gone against my intuition
a lot specifically in relationships
like i'll get into relationships i'm
like this is not the right thing for me
but something is telling me like i wanna
conquer this or i wanna help this person
i wanna i'm desiring this and then
i stay in it way too long and my
intuition is like get out but my head is
like yeah but what about this and it's
fulfilling this need
and every time something doesn't work
out and i knew i knew it wasn't going to
work out my intuition's telling me like
why are you doing this inhabit number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is show up with grant
cardone showing up means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand it doesn't mean you came
to work
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off
i was acting a fool
being a fool
high school i didn't show up i went to
class i never showed up
my body went in the room
see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there and
then you showed up again and then you
showed up again and you showed up again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test you freaking get a
perfect grade means you keep showing up
to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way
when you show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success
that means you show up and then you show
up again you show up again you keep
getting better at your game you can't
keep showing up as the old you
you got to show up as the new you
you know mercedes-benz if they just kept
building this vehicle the way they used
to build it
and didn't keep showing up with new
technology
new suspension
new seats
new choices new colors
you know the matte black
the red guts
new navigation system you gotta have a
new game every day baby you gotta have a
new game every day and the follow up you
gotta have
you got to have a new follow up can't
have a new i can't can't do the same
thing you did that didn't work yesterday
we're doing a 10x growth conference i'm
doing a 10x this year i'm not doing the
same 10x i did last year it's a new year
new time new audience new speakers
now that being said when i show up in
the 10x growth conference in las vegas
on 2 20 20 20
i just spent six hours this morning
working out what we're doing
okay
i'm not gonna show up the way i did last
year jumping out of a damn plane
i'm gonna show up in a different way
okay in a different way in a unique way
but i am not gonna abandon the things
that work for the audience and for
myself
so you got to find this really really
cool mixture between
repeating what works
and showing up as a new person all the
time
if you're reading a book
okay you listening to music
going to an event
uh
speaking at an event
let's say you're speaking in an event
it's it's the 700th time you did that
presentation you got to show up new
again
johnny comes to work with his camera and
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new
you got to show up every day new folks
you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new
every day you're new or
guess what you're old
[Music]
nobody wants old
i don't want to get old
i don't want stale
i don't want yesterdays
i don't want leftovers
i don't i don't i know i know when
somebody's repeating something wrote
they're just giving me the same
i don't mind some [ __ ] but it's got
to be fresh
i need some fresh [ __ ]
so i don't i don't mind a little bit of
[ __ ] i just don't want the same
thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand thousand times not in a good
way either so you gotta keep showing up
showing up means you're looking for
deeper levels to show up to pay
attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem show up for
every little opportunity show up for
every little little new nuance
little angle little particle little
movement that's why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what's it why don't
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here
hey you feeling all right today how many
times have i asked you that before you
all right today i know it's little
things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up
it costs you nothing
and it makes all the difference man it's
showing up
you'll see things that no one else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just gotta make
a commitment to show up
you have the power to control your world
how you think how you act your mindset
with the words that you speak when you
use weak language you signal to yourself
that you are weak you signal to yourself
that your goals aren't important you
signal to yourself that you are not
worth it you lose respect for yourself
and the people around you don't respect
you either we need to stop using weak
language and pay attention to the words
that you're speaking to others and to
yourself now this is not an easy task
because most of the words that you're
using the way that you talk to others
into yourself you're on autopilot you're
on cruise control it just happens you've
been doing this for years or decades and
so switching it is not going to happen
overnight but if you pay attention to
the next three things that i'm going to
share with you it can have a dramatic
impact on your self-confidence and the
goals that you have for yourself and on
the outcomes you create for yourself and
the world let's do it number one i can't
i'm not i don't what you say after those
three things shapes your identity it
speaks to how you think and speak about
yourself
so i can't i can't be an entrepreneur i
can't be a leader i can't be a youtuber
i can't i can't i can't i can't i can't
especially this one when you say i can't
pay very very very very very very close
attention to what follows and try
and try and try to shift it from i can't
to either i choose not to or i can't yet
i'm not
i'm not a good salesperson i'm not funny
i'm not the kind of person who follows
through again pay close attention and
try to shift it to not yet
i don't
i don't program i don't know how to make
money i don't think like that
switch i don't do i don't yet i can't
i'm not i don't those statements are
final those statements don't allow for
growth those statements are how you feel
about yourself and don't allow for the
stretch they don't allow you to get
better and so either eliminate them from
your vocabulary or change them to yet
number two is catch your cruise control
the way that you have been speaking
about yourself the way that you have
been talking to yourself has been
happening using the same words for years
maybe even decades it's so automatic for
you you are on cruise control you are on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself without even
thinking about it you need to catch your
cruise control and listen don't be too
hard on yourself this is so ingrained
these patterns have been around for so
long you are just auto defaulting to
cruise control that most of these times
you will not even catch it you will not
catch 99
of these moments of these words of these
languages that you're using for yourself
but if you have the awareness if you
have the intention if you have the
desire every now and then you will catch
it another quick hack is to enlist a
friend and list the people around you
your wife your husband your team your
kids kids especially my son hayden loves
calling me out on things enlist their
help tell them this is where i want to
play a bigger game this is where i'm
frustrated with myself this is where i
keep talking badly about myself and
putting myself down these are the words
the language that i need to change
and every time you hear me talking this
way i need you to bring it to my
awareness and let me know because i want
to catch my cruise control for me
personally it's around complaining
anytime i complain i want my wife i want
my team i want my son i want the people
around me to say evan you are
complaining right there that was a
complaint eat it right i'm happy for
them to hug me with it to yell at me
with it i just want them to let me know
now when i told everybody they said
listen you barely complain you're like
the least complaining person that we
know
awesome thank you i'm humbled but i
still complain and i probably complain a
lot and a lot of the times i'm missing
it and so please please please please
please please please even if you think
i'm great at it if you catch me
complaining i want you to call me out on
it so enlisting your friends can be
really helpful because you will likely
not catch most of them yourself but it's
imperative that you start working on
catching your cruise control step number
three is manual override you have caught
your cruise control you have found the
autopilot it's about to happen again
this negative talk that you're about to
speak out into the world about yourself
or your ideas you putting yourself down
is about to come out again or has just
come out what do you do about it because
this is really important
if you catch yourself playing small or
talking negatively about yourself if you
catch it
and you don't do anything it actually
makes it worse
it's better that you don't even catch it
at all
if you catch it and you recognize i am
playing small right now
and you ignore it and you don't change
your behavior you are building that
identity for yourself that you are
somebody who is playing small
you are consciously building that
identity for yourself and you need to
stop it
it makes it worse
where when you do catch it
when you find yourself falling into
those patterns those behaviors that you
don't want anymore whether you find it
yourself or somebody's calling you out
on it
what do you do you need to kick your
manual override into action and take the
action that you want because that starts
building the positive habit that starts
building the positive respect this is
how you build respect for yourself this
is how you start building the muscle
this isn't just a zero-sum game this
isn't just we go back to neutral
when you catch it you either go sliding
down or you go propelling up
the choice is yours when you catch
yourself playing small when you catch
yourself coming off a cruise control
you have to do the thing
that builds the self-respect up and
speak positively about yourself and do
the thing that you are scared to do the
most powerful way
and the easiest way to change your
thermostat setting is by adding people
to your circle very close proximity that
live at a higher temperature in that
area than you do for example in your
faith let's just say you're a 75 degree
or in your faith you've already seen
this you can't possibly begin to
regularly associate with good godly
people who pray regularly who try to
live righteously and they're 110 120
degrees of of faith in their life and
not have that proximity heat you up now
you won't get to where they are you'll
get to somewhere between where you are
at 75 degrees and they are at 110 over
time you become 100 degree and you alter
the thermostat setting through
association same in business if you and
i were to hang around each other every
single day and let's say you were a 75
degree or in business hypothetically and
i don't know that about you but let's
just say you were
and i was 150 degree and we hung around
each other all the time don't you think
through that association especially if
you had two or three or four people like
me in your life that just over time you
don't even feel it you're at 80 you're
85 you're at 90 you're at 95 and that's
where you are we understand the power of
this with our children because we know
at school the teachers have influence
over them they're mentors but the people
that really have influence over our
children are for their friends because
they're around them all the time and so
we know it's that's their temperature
this is true in fitness if you're a 75
degree of fitness at every meal every
day at the gym all your associations
hypothetically speaking where with
someone who was shredded and fit the way
you wanted to look at 150 degrees you
know over time you get heated up and so
you can't be with someone every day you
can't be with them all the time but the
key is to get more proximity in the
areas that matter with people whose
thermostat setting is higher than yours
i am a product you are listening to me
right now because i've been so obsessed
with this concept of adding new
associations to my life that live in the
areas that i want to improve in at
higher temperatures than me it's my
obsession to this day i'll give you a
secret one of the reasons i even do my
show is i know that i'm influencing many
of these guests in the areas that matter
most to them through our proximity and
in some cases they do it for me and so
i'm obsessed with the power of
association but i don't just associate
see
all personnel says yeah you're the five
people you hang around kinda
you really are the five to ten people
you hang around if you're conscious all
the time
of studying them of observing them of
asking questions of the fact that you
should be altering your thermostat
setting that's when it really moves it's
not just hanging around it's consciously
and intentionally spending time with
people
where you allow it to impact you where
you study them where you really observe
them where you're open to their
influence there has to be a level of
trust before you can do that where you
surrender yourself to them but it's not
just being around them it's
intentionally being around people that
alters that thermostat setting so power
of association is the main way to do it
over my career and
i've been in business over 20 years now
people from all around the world
students at every level
whether they are
newly into launching their business or
they've been in business themselves for
10 15 years
ask the question how do i overcome fear
i'm about to disrupt you
completely
because i am not
going to give you a strategy to overcome
fear
because if i even attempt to give you a
strat and i know we're always looking at
stuff reading things how to overcome
fears they're probably 10 steps to
overcoming fear somewhere out there they
weren't written by me and i could never
write it
because i don't think
you wait to overcome fear
to live the life of your dreams or the
one that you deserve or to blow your own
mind
i personally and i'm teaching you from
my
life lessons from what i've studied what
i've applied what i've implemented what
i've fallen from
what i've soared from what i've gotten
up from
and
i don't think you focus on learning how
to overcome fear though there are things
that helps to mitigate your fear
information mitigates fear
training and developing your skill set
mitigates fear i teach speaking i love
teaching people how to speak powerfully
not to speak to be great but to speak to
be unforgettable whether you're a
speaker or whether you're a manager
whether you're in retails or network
marketing whatever it is when you open
your mouth you won't be unforgettable
and people always say lisa how do i
overcome the fear of speaking i said
let's not focus
on the fear of speaking because energy
grows where energy goes so let's not
focus on overcoming fear
let's focus on building a muscle
that naturally dissolves fear
and that muscle is the muscle of
information the muscle of education and
the muscle of skill set so if you know
more
and then you develop the skill set you
won't be as afraid to do that thing that
you're talking about but the other side
to that now i'm going to disrupt you a
bit so the first part not so disruptive
that means go get more information
give fear what fear needs to to to
reduce itself meaning information skill
set but this other part that i'm going
to tell you this might be disruptive how
about
you not try
to mitigate resolve or get past or
overcome whatever you want to call how
about you not try to do that with fear
how about you allow to fear to sit with
you
you just commit to keep moving
even with the fear
so many times in my life and in my
career i was afraid
the difference between me and most is
that i still move forward with the fear
fear does not have a pass to stop you
fear does not have a pass to stop you
first of all let me just tell you this
just like compassion just like love just
like respect just like any other feeling
you feel for someone fear is just a
feeling we just give fear more power we
say when compassion comes i hug i love
when understanding comes when joy comes
when humor comes i laugh
but when fear comes i get to stop what
if you change the meaning to that oh
just just stick with me right here
what if
you change your dance with fear
what if you tell fear you're welcome
in my life because you're gonna come
can't keep your way
but when you come
i'm not going to stop i quoted andrew
carnegie a few minutes ago
he said any idea that's held in the mind
that's emphasized that's either feared
or revered
begins at once to clothe itself in the
most convenient and appropriate form
available
depression
comes it starts out from ignorance doubt
and worry
i've got a chart i show it
doubt and worry
is on the negative side of life
understanding is on the positive side
don't worry comes from ignorance
understanding comes from knowledge but
you got to study to get it
done and worry are a psychic disease
it's an intellectual exercise
they're using their intellectual factors
to build a negative idea
and that's all they see
they take and internalize that and they
get emotionally involved with it it goes
from don't worry to fear
they've emotionalized the doubt or worry
turns into fear
the fear is in the emotional mind
and the emotion must be expressed
through the only instrument that can be
expressed through the physical body
so it moves the body into a state we
call anxiety
anxiety is never expressed anxiety
suppressed
the suppression turns to depression
they've all led up inside they
suppressed the fear
it turns into depression the depression
turns into disease
the disease turns into decay saint
claire lewis was right he said we don't
die we kill herself now what is the
opposite of all that you go from
ignorance to don't worry to fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration go over on the other side
you go from understanding
to emotional state called faith you just
know it's going to move into form
because you understand the law
faith doesn't believe in something you
can't see
strange thing about faith and fear they
both demand you believe something you
can't see
why would people choose fear over faith
because they're ignorant
so you go from understanding to faith
the faith manifests on the physical
plane not as anxiety as well-being
the well-being is not suppressed it's
expressed
and the expression turns to acceleration
you're building energy
and that is because there's no disease
you're at ease
and that turns into creation not
disintegration
it's all it's all a mental trip that
they're building
now they go to the doctor the doctor
gives them valium or some kind of drug
to cool them out
he gets them numb so they don't know
what the hell they're doing when you
really look at the credit it is
improved nutrition and sanitation
so people were dying of malnutrition
which made them more susceptible to
infections and other disorders
and then sanitation and vaccination
that's how we it's not antibiotics let's
say it's not pharmaceuticals it's still
conditions of living you know better
hygiene better nutrition
but now
the increment to that
is understanding what causes accelerated
aging lack of sleep
stress
unhealthy emotions like hostility and
anger
and resentments and guilt and shame and
depression and anxiety lack of mind-body
coordination that's where the yoga and
the breathing techniques come in
poor nutrition right now most of our
food
that
comes
to us
at home
is manufactured refined processed
contains chemicals contains antibiotics
contains steroids because animals are
fed that and even you know there are
pesticides in the ground which are
petroleum products how does that cause
accelerated aging it causes inflammation
of something called the microbiome which
is
the genes that are in your gut which are
microbial genes
so 99
of the genetic information in your body
right now
is not human you only have one percent
of the genes in your body are from your
parents
99 of the genes in your body right now
are microbial you're a few humans i'm a
mutant i'm like an x-man
i like that you're a few human cells
hanging on to a bacterial column
so when you put food in your mouth the
first thing that they encounter the food
encounters is these bacterial genes and
if your food is inflamed then the
bacterial genes get inflamed causes
inflammation in the body you get
metabolites
that are called cytokines there's lots
of complexity of course you struggle to
remember it in your day-to-day life
because life is difficult and it's
harder to do things than not to do them
and it's harder to do them well than to
do them badly you know and it's easy to
sit around and be hopeless i don't mean
it's emotionally easy because it's not
but it's procedurally easy to be useless
and to fall back into your old habits
and to not discipline yourself and
it's it's a matter of continual practice
slow continual practice and i think a
good example of that is something like
weight lifting you know if you start a
weight lifting program which i would
recommend by the way because it it's
tremendously advantageous physically and
cognitively
you're not going to really see results
for a number of weeks and then the
results are rather slow but you can get
pretty decent results over a six month
period and absolutely stellar results
over a couple of years and so you have
to make sure your time frame is right
and not to be too hard on yourself and i
did mention the future authoring program
um earlier
and one of the things i would recommend
too is if you're having a hard time
implementing your
your decisions say your ethical
decisions that you spend a bit more time
thinking them through and writing them
down and the future authoring program is
really helpful for that that's why we
designed it
and so
get your goals straight and continue to
practice every day and if you're not
succeeding then make your goals slightly
smaller you want to you want to make
your goals large enough so that they
challenge you but small enough so that
you have a reasonable probability of
succeeding at them on a day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day like
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think oh my god
now i've screwed it up i've i'm not
quitting anymore you smoke a whole pack
of cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed it just means
that you had a cigarette you can start
stopping again the next day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that
and so you've got to be
realistically humble you've got to be
ambitious enough in your goals so that
you're pursuing something that you
regard as truly meaningful and
worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
the problem is shutting down emotionally
is you stop learning
emotional learning stops when you shut
down
so you shut down to protect yourself
but for development you need
vulnerability vulnerability from the
latin word vulnerary will nerari the
wound
so vulnerabilities are capacity to be
wounded
and nothing grows when it's not
vulnerable
a tree doesn't grow where it's hard and
thick it goes where it's soft and green
and vulnerable a crustacean animal like
a crab cannot grow
encased in a hard shell to grow
it has to mold make itself soft and
vulnerable same with children
when children shut down emotionally
they have difficulty learning especially
from negative experience
so they keep repeating the same stuff
over and over again and despite the
negative consequences they learn nothing
from it
and then the adult gets exasperated
i've told him a thousand times not to do
it and you're still doing it
well the proper response is
if you've told him a thousand times
and he's still doing it who's got the
learning problem here
clearly what clearly what we have to do
clearly what we have to do is we have to
find out what's going on when you focus
on where you want to go you actually go
towards it the more you focus on where
you want to be the more your mind like a
heat seeking missile takes you to where
you
want to be
so if you want to be an olympic athlete
you'd have to take a lot of action you
have to practice a lot and train a lot
if you don't want to do something
physical
train your mind practice with your mind
use mood boards i've done quite a few
radio interviews about why mood boards
are so successful why people
who have everything tend to have mood
boards now the mood board i made years
ago i put it above my bed
which is an odd thing to do actually
because i face away from it so i don't
look at it every day anymore but a
little while ago i looked at it and i
realized that
every single thing i put on that mood
board had come true in fact when i
finished with all the um
things i was going to do as a writer i
put up some pictures one was hot air
ballooning and one was something else
and i realized that every single thing
i'd put up i think one was riding a
camel i'd actually done all of those so
i thought well i better make a new mood
board now with new things i want i wrote
down some of the countries i wanted to
go to
so if you put it above your bed do make
sure that you look at it better to put
it really on your fridge
or in your kitchen or in your office you
can also take a big photograph of it and
make that your screen saver
and the wallpaper on your phone because
then of course you will look at it every
day over and over again
but even though i made that mood board
and put it in a place where i didn't
look at it and actually looked away from
it guess what it still worked so imagine
how it will work if it's right in your
line of vision if it's on your computer
screen and i work with many many women
who are having huge problems conceiving
and i get them to make a baby board same
thing but it's a picture of a positive
pregnancy test colored into yes it's
lots of pictures of babies
i have them also put that on instagram
and on their computer screen so they see
it every day and the success rates with
using that baby board are
phenomenal
make your mood board how many people do
you know maybe even you
have a job that just kills you it's
draining your energy you hate going
there maybe even a company that you
started that you thought was going to be
exciting but just it's just robbing the
life out of you or even school maybe
you're in college or even high school
and and it just every moment of it is
frustrating and here's what we do we
think to ourselves when i get out of
this job and i start my own company then
i'm going to be fired up then i'm going
to be excited then i'm going to take my
life to the next level when i get out of
school i'm going gonna do it when i when
i throw this company away and i start
the new company and guess what that's
the worst thinking that type of thinking
will keep you
exactly where you are so let me just
give you an example
i don't know if you know this about me
but when i was in my teens and my 20s i
worked on cars every single day of my
life i had a collision repair shop i i
got wrecked cars and people brought them
in and i fixed them i sucked fumes every
day i had dirt under my nails every
night i was literally scraping under my
nails trying to get piles of dirt out i
changed motors i did i rebuilt
carburetors i mean the worst thing i
hated was painting the cars because i
got such a headache even though we had
good ventilation i'd get such a headache
from the fumes but that's what i did did
i love painting cars
no i absolutely despised it i hated
every bit of it but i was lucky enough
to realize
that how you do any job is how you do
every job
and what i had to do was find things
that were exciting in that job because i
knew it was the stepping stone so here's
what i i believe so many people hate
what they do their lack of energy when
you don't like something you're not
enthusiastic you're not excited you're
not nice to people so you're just
thinking i'm gonna get in this groove
but then something's gonna snap and then
all of a sudden i'm gonna be amazing i'm
gonna be excited i'm gonna i'm gonna
find that new job that new career no you
have to start now so what you have to do
like i did with the collision shop is
you have to find a way for that dull job
that thing that robs your energy now to
be exciting yes you do as hard as that
sounds
do it to the best of your ability and
guess what opportunity comes along in
places you won't even realize uh that
there isn't even there's an opportunity
for you example so i'm in the car
business hating it but i found a way to
be enthusiastic because what i liked is
i like the fact that a car would come in
wrecked i could visualize it looking
perfect again and visualize how excited
the person would be to get their car
back to new so when i was working on
cars i didn't think oh i got
bondo on my fingertips paint on my nails
i got a headache from the fumes i'm
dirty it's sweaty if i thought about
that everything would have sucked but
what i thought about was how excited the
person's gonna be when they see their
car back to normal and i found a way to
be enthusiastic and excited if you asked
anybody like that guy loves collision
work
it's not true i wasn't lying i found a
way to manipulate myself so
in that instance my first big real
estate deal i did several with no money
down worked right my butt off to to get
it done but my first big real estate
deal that after years uh was the first
deal i did over a million dollars on
true story in my little town in upstate
new york a town called marlboro new york
and guess who i did the deal with
somebody who came into the collision
shop and i did work on their car lent me
the money because i was so enthusiastic
so excited such in a good mood the guy's
like how do you have so much energy how
are you so excited i said well this is
just a stepping stone for me i'm working
on real estate deals i've done a few and
working on this bigger one he's like
well why aren't you doing the big one
like i'm trying to put the money
together but i'll get it i know i'll
make it that guy lent me 80 000
just like that and he made a ton of
money for it i mean i i was so
appreciative of the loan he gave me i
did everything in my power to make sure
that deal i think the thing that people
misunderstand about success
is
they're looking for the easiest way to
get there
you know and it's funny how many people
books have you read or
i won't say promoted but had on your
show and everybody goes five easy steps
ten steps to greatness yeah no
eight steps to this and
those steps for success they're infinite
they are
infinite you cannot
count them
it doesn't matter how long you've been
doing it those steps are constantly
shifting
you don't know if they're there
sometimes you have to trust that the
next step is going to be there when you
can't even see it and sometimes when you
step on that step you go right into
quicksand but you got to be able to
pull yourself back out of it again so
everybody's looking for these steps and
there are no steps so steps never never
end and you just can't climb steps
sometimes you got to crawl though those
steps and you finally get to the top
and everything shifts and you're at the
bottom it's crazy
all right what is that what does that
mean sometimes you're at the top and
then you're at the bottom again well you
may get to the top and you're like i'm
here
and then you look back down and you look
up again you're actually on the first
step
you're on the first step again
and where you thought was the top is not
even the top it's the beginning wow it's
literally the beginning
of where you're supposed to be
and that's when most people just quit it
i just like it just drives me crazy
because everybody's like here look at
i always people that i do the interview
with i always like to use them as an
example because people can relate to
that all right
you've been climbing steps for how long
to get to here
to get
i mean since starting this it's been
over eight years but the journey before
then
it was you know decades to build myself
to prepare myself for this and now i
feel like i'm just getting started right
exactly so you absolutely right exactly
so all the steps that you climbed just
to get started yeah
just to get started and people don't
want to talk about those steps they
don't want to talk about those steps and
how difficult those steps are and how
many steps that you stumbled on and how
many steps you didn't even see and how
many steps that people placed in front
of you when they pulled and they pulled
them off pulled away people that you
were very close to people that you knew
that people that you thought that were
like hey these people actually have my
back except yeah they did have your back
but they were actually pushing you down
the steps
yes
no and
it's funny when you talk about those
things or people talk about them they
seem surprised but you should know that
in that path all those things are going
to be there if i'm having
some dark days and sad times i'm like i
got to get progress so what i'll do is
i'll identify with my five major moves
if you read this book high performance
habits you know about the five major
moves so identify my five major moves
and i'm like i'll swiftly move towards
one because momentum can shift mindset
and so if i'm in dark disappointment
down momentum like achieve some goals
but here's what's important notice i
said the five major moves
that's what i mean with progress because
what a lot of people mistakenly do is
they just start doing lots of tasks and
activities that aren't correlated in any
way to the meaningful pursuits of life
so here's what happened
i'm bummed i'm down so i'm doing a bunch
of work
the next day they still feel bummed and
down because what was their work it was
a bunch of activities that actually
didn't matter
that didn't give them any meaning
so if you're down
the most important working you'll be
doing is the ones that you do feel
connection enthusiasm meaning
fulfillment satisfaction from
those ones that do intrinsically bring
you joy
those the ones that i want you to
progress towards matter of fact i really
want you when you're feeling down
disappointed major setbacks dark days
what i really desperately want you to do
is stop multitasking and doing all the
little like busy work things that don't
matter
like
like put off like
if it's wednesday and
you know you got a stack of bills and
they're not due
for another 30 days
don't pay the bills that day because
that's not fun and you're you got plenty
of time to do it later when you fee like
when you get over this piece this funk
like just say okay write the date on
those bills pay them on but don't do it
today
because that's busy work instead today
find an activity that you find to be
creative compelling engaging fulfilling
and do that progress towards the things
that have meaning
that's huge when you're down
but most people don't do that because
what's comforting just like eating
comfort food
is doing low hanging fruit activity
i'll pay the bills and answer a bunch of
emails you know but those small little
tasks
those don't give you enough bang for the
buck to really move through it and
there's a big misconception about that
in the culture including the science
that often says oh no no just you know
if people can complete small steps
small tasks
they'll feel better
and it's like
well yeah i mean we all have this reward
system in our brain and a little
dopamine will fall out but do we do we
want a little
drip drip of dopamine or we want the
floodgates to come open and feel alive i
turned it around you know i
i did my job
in four hours and i was on there there
was a wall that separated production
from the offices and the lunchrooms
because in production there was you know
quality control you couldn't go in there
unless you had hair nets and you know
protective equipment
so what i did is i borrowed some
protective equipment i went in there and
i started hanging out with the operators
the people that were running the lines
and i started taking their trash outside
and then
if they want this is cool this is the
truth i don't know you know people will
like it but if they wanted a cigarette
break
you know to go outside and smoke you
know this is this is 70 right you know
everybody smokes uh so i would say well
just show me what to do you know you
just be gone for five minutes and
they're like uh i don't know like oh
come on just i'm i'm a mechanic you know
and i really am
you know and so they would teach me you
know uh how to watch the line and they
would go outside
you know and i'd do that for a couple of
weeks and so so the other managers were
telling my manager like hey uh
the guy on your crew that mops in the
night man hey uh i just want to thank
you for letting him take my trash out my
guys helped him and they were like what
who did that
you know and he was like like okay he
was like no one had ever done that
you know you heard the old statement
that's not my job
after he told after he told me that i i
never said i said i'm employed here that
is my job
you know
that is my job and
and little by little i learned how to
run the the dorito lines
you know how to and it is it is like
being a pilot it's not you know people
say you just make chips oh no no no man
it's like you got to go to pilot school
to learn how to make
doritos and potato chips and fritos
believe me it takes a couple years to be
a master we all come to a relationship
with like expectations about how we
think people should act and
unfortunately we don't recognize our
expectations as expectations we
recognize them as truth this is how the
world is it is how the world should be
and when somebody we think that they
have those same beliefs and values and
rules and all that and so given this
scenario there's only one way to act
that is certainly obvious and so when
the person doesn't act like that we take
it personally like whoa do you not
respect me do you not love me do you not
care about me and it just isn't that
they have a different set of beliefs and
rules there's enough nuance difference
that they're not if they're intending to
hurt you you have a whole different set
of problems but assuming that they're
not intending to hurt you then you have
a communication problem so lisa and i
actually define our terms so we have a
few words in our
marriage that they mean something so if
i say hey baby it's important to me that
you leave that you know glass of water
on the table then there she just
wouldn't move it period simple as like
the the word important like comes in all
caps with exclamation points glowing red
like that's like when we say it like
it's a drop whatever you're doing like
it's important that you do x y z now the
big thing is when you define a word like
that you can't ever abuse it so like i
would never say it's important to me
that you leave that you know it's got to
be it's just extraordinary like how many
times do i tell her something's
important in a year
i don't know six seven times in a year
so it's like it's really got to be
limited and then another one is promise
if i say i promise i'm gonna do that
dude i'm going to
do
that like there's no two ways about it
so you never throw around promise ever
under any circumstance and so dude it's
like you really really have to be
hardcore and so and the other way that
we use promise is um if if uh she says
you know how does this dress look on me
i'm like yeah it looks great and she's
like you promise
then it's like all right all right it
makes you look fat what can i say i mean
it's like but then you you cut to like
the chase on something now the thing is
you can't say that all the time you
can't be like how's this dress make me
look fine promise uh what do you think
of this dinner you like it yeah i love
it promise like if you're doing that it
loses everything but if you're saving it
for like in fact god i almost don't
remember the last time i asked lisa to
promise something like that um but
you know that you haven't we certainly
use it more in the early days of our
marriage but even then like how many
times a year three or four i mean it's
like but it really forces you to respect
these things you make sacred in your
relationship
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to develop good habits
and break bad habits check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there one of the laws is to make it
obvious and this largely comes down to
like what we're exposed to each year
each day and minimalism and simplicity
plays a big role in this um in the book
i call it environment design that's
basically the strategy